[Music]
fiancee lends a helping hand to
hurricane Harvey victims between be paid
a visit to her hometown Church in
Houston Texas to aid in hurricane relief
after the natural disaster left the city
flooded and his soul sentimental Sam
Beyonce here that she had been able to
come for a long time only ET was inside
the service as Blue Ivy Beyonce and Tina
Lawson attended a special service it
wasn't long before the formation singer
and her mother Tina took to the stage to
speak to the congregation
[Music]
and I just want to thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
she started singing on the stage it was
very emotional
mama Tina also left evacuees with some
encouraging words she wants receive from
their pastor earlier in the day Tina and
former Destiny's Child member Michelle
Williams fed those in need through the
be good foundation Houston resident
Craig Minzy know who attended the
gathering told ET quote they're greeting
everyone making them all feel special at
one point our insider says Tina was
heard encouraging the victims to
continue to be strong you know it's just
this is the celebration that was still
here not not as fatty business the
celebration of survivor
[Music]
you